un monticule de déchets encore fumant
après l incendie qui s'est déclaré
samedi à la plateforme de tri et de
voyages des encombrants de
fort-de-france leur est au déblaiement
depuis ce matin plusieurs engins
s'activent pour libérer les accès et
effectuer un premier tri nous avons un
bâtiment détruit au trois quarts et puis
beaucoup de déchet à pouvoir orienter
vers les filières dans la mesure des
possibilités
en attendant les arrivages donc ombres
ont été déroutés vers l' usine de petits
galion à trinité ce matin encore on
ignorait les causes exactes de
l'incendié
tout en pointant du doigt l'incivisme
des usagers malheureusement le trier à
la sauce n'est pas suffisamment bien
fait et lorsque les déchets arrivent ici
nous avons un second tri à faire et
quelquefois nous sommes surpris de
constater des fusées de détresse et
d'autres objets
amené à pouvoir s'enflammer des déchets
dangereux comme sont entreposés à
quelques mètres de là écarté de la
chaîne de tri par les opérateurs du site
on les a récupérés on appelle
prestataires qui est ce qu'on retrouve
la danse à bas débit de gaz des
inspecteurs au sol chaque année ce sont
quarante mille tonnes d'encombrants qui
sont collectées et traitées conviendrait
déjà continue une production des chaires
martinique allocs la population diminuer
les la production de déchets augmente ça
c'est une bizarrerie n'arrivons pas à
comprendre mais il faut également que
nous les usagers fassent le tri et nous
avons 13 déchetterie sur le territoire
nous ne pouvons avoir tant de dépôts
sauvages notamment à quelques mètres de
chaque déchetterie ce matin les
responsables de la plateforme était
optimiste quant à une reprise rapide de
l'activité
s'agissant de l' incendie de samedi une
plainte pourrait être déposée